zack bonjour merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors une baisse de 5
0% du pib
pouvait-on s'attendre à une telle
récession selon vous oui bonjour les
projections que notre cabinet avait
avait mené excusez moi dès le début d'
du confinement porté à satan dans
quelque chose d'aussi catastrophique
puisque le confinement et les mesures de
confinement était radicale d'après but
économique
je pense que personne n'est surpris
peut-être à par le gouvernement lui-même
pourquoi l'économie du pays est elle à
ce point affaibli écouter parce que le
pays est entré dans cette période de
crise déjà excessivement fragilisé par
dix ans de décroissance de
désinvestissement de crise de
gouvernance ainsi que de crise
économique profonde
illustré par la paire n crise de
production d'électricité par la société
étatique s comme est donc le pays s'est
vu d industrialiser de manière accélérée
tous les secteurs productifs sont en
berne depuis un certain nombre d'années
et l'activité économique des cinq à six
dernières années a été tenu par la
consommation du public la consommation
des ménages et par la dette publique
mais celles ci ont été deux largement
insuffisante générer de l'emploi de
masse et on se retrouve avec une
économique et une économie
je dirais vide sans fondement de
croissance durable l'activité minière
n'est plus ce qu'elle était l'activité
manufacturière n'est plus ce qu'elle
était et ce sont toutes les bases de la
compétitivité de ce pays qui ont été si
vous voulez abîmé par une choix de
stratégie de la nc qui est en fait un
échec structurelles profondes
alors quand on voit justement ces
chiffres alarmants on peut se poser la
question si c'est le gouvernement sud
africain a vraiment réussi
gérer cette crise sanitaire écoutez je
pense que à ce niveau là il faut
reconnaître que le gouvernement a pris
les mesures qui de mon point de vu
s'imposer tout en sachant qu'il y aurait
un impact socio économique grave mais je
pense que peut-être un manque de
réalisations de la nécessité d'utiliser
cette crise pour fondamentalement
restructurer l'économie
imaginez ceux ci c'est un pays de 50
millions d'habitants à peine 10 millions
de personnes sont employées dans le
secteur formel de manière durable avec
des salaires une baisse attendue de
l'ordre de 1.5 million à deux millions
d'emplois voudrait dire qu'on passerait
de l'ordre de 20% de la population du
pays employés à peut-être 15 % c'est
complètement intenable le problème
fondamental il est dans des logiques
puisque l'insee et ses partenaires
notamment les syndicats se refuse à si
vous voulez ouvrir l'économie à l'emploi
de masse il ya cette espèce de donc
mobilation vis-à-vis des secteurs à
haute intensité capitalistique et
technologique dans un pays qui n'a pas
la ressource humaine pas les capacités
pas les infrastructures pour si vous
voulez prendre ce chemin de
développement
donc il faut impérativement compenser
les effets socio économiques les plus
graves
ce qui veut dire par nécessité augmenter
la dette à court terme pour protéger les
plus pauvres et arrêter ce que votre
reportage noter c'est à dire
l'augmentation intenable de la pauvreté
des inégalités tout en prenant des
mesures de restructuration économique
brave courageuse mais politiquement
impopulaire
dernière question la banque mondiale
décrit l'afrique du sud comme l'un des
pays les plus inégalitaires au monde
qu'elle elle
le risque d'une telle crise écoutez on
n'y est pas plus loin que chez moi là où
je suis nous sommes visiter tous les
jours par des dizaines de personnes
appauvries qui n'ont pas d'emploi qui
n'ont pas de logement qui n'ont pas de
quoi vivre et qu'il faut utiliser que le
système si vous voulez de solidarité
sociale étatique n'est pas en mesure de
soutenir
donc il faut absolument trouver une
solution d'urgence
sinon le pays s'enfoncera dans une crise
non seulement économique et sociale mais
une crise politique
au fond je vois à l'écran des images des
militants de la fff le grand danger
c'est que face à cette situation
comme dans beaucoup des pays d'afrique
par le passé l'affaiblissement du
secteur formel la disparition ou là
c'est une demande de la classe moyenne
amène à une radicalisation politique
bien une croissance d des politiques
populistes avec appelle la
nationalisation des mines des banques
etc
ce qui serait évidemment un clou dans le
cercueil de l'afrique du sud
donc voilà la situation elle est
extrêmement grave nous venons d'écrire
dans le magazine daily malgré un article
qui fait le bilan si vous voulez de 25 à
30 ans d'erreurs stratégiques avec
l'identification d'un changement radical
il faut que l'afrique du sud épouse les
stratégies qui ont été épousé dans les
années 70 80 par les pays d'asie du sud
du sud-est ouverture massive aux
investissements étrangers dans les
secteurs particuliers capables créer de
l'emploi tout en s'attachant à réformer
de manière douce progressive les
secteurs qui sont les secteurs si vous
voulez ou les où les intérêts
euh capitalistique ou les intérêts des
syndicats etc résistent à la réforme
il faut trouver une approche totalement
nouvelle sinon d'ici 2030 2035 l'afrique
du sud sera un état famille
merci beaucoup en tout cas claude
baissac d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous étiez en direct de
johannesburg où vous êtes économiste et
fondateur du cabinet de conseil